this week congress is set to take action
on another pressing issue the nationwide
shortage of baby formula the house plans
to take up a pair of emergency measures
to help boost supply congressional
correspondent nicole killian is on
capitol hill nicole what can parents
expect
well nate the measures the house will
consider this week aim to fill the void
on store shelves lawmakers are working
on a bill that would enable the u.s to
buy more formula from other countries
like mexico and ireland to increase
supply they'll also consider a bill that
would loosen restrictions for parents in
the wic program which aids low-income
families despite recent calls for the
white house to use the defense
production act to produce more formula
house speaker nancy pelosi argues it's
not legally possible this week fda
commissioner robert calif will appear
before a congressional committee where
he's expected to face questions on the
shortage and the federal response a
house oversight panel has also requested
information from some of the major
manufacturers of infant formula to find
out what they're doing to ramp up
production nate
nicole i'll take it thank you very much